permitiría es que netflix decidiera por
vosotros
que se eligiera el restaurante al que
vais a cenar esta noche o que spotify os
indicará las canciones que vais a
escuchar mañana
todavía no pero día a día la
inteligencia artificial está tomando más
decisiones por nosotros y curiosamente
sus decisiones van encaminadas a
beneficiar a las empresas que
desarrollan e implementan inteligencia
artificial y cuál es la base de esta
tecnología cuál es la base de la
inteligencia artificial las matemáticas
es asignatura que nos encantaba a todos
de pequeños
y en concreto las matemáticas no nos la
han ansiado como lo que son un lenguaje
sino como otra materia más que memorizar
como historia o biología pero son otra
forma de escribir la realidad y es el
lenguaje que hablan las máquinas
y en concreto la inteligencia artificial
tiene su base en los algoritmos que no
son más que una serie de instrucciones
matemáticas hay un símil muy bueno que
es que son como una receta culinaria a
saber
mezclamos huevos levadura y yogur y
harina mezclamos bien vertemos en un
molde que metemos en un horno
precalentado a 150 grados y tras 30 a 40
minutos tendremos un exquisito bizcocho
hemos tenido una entrada de información
una receta bien estipulada y una salida
que es diferente a lo que teníamos al
principio
y ahora estos algoritmos se dice que son
nada más ni nada menos que inteligentes
sí que son inteligentes porque son
capaces de aprender se entrenan
es decir de una gran cantidad de datos
son capaces de extraer unos patrones y
unos hábitos y darnos unas conclusiones
tremendamente precisas
y no dejamos de ver todo lo que puede
hacer esta inteligencia artificial es
capaz de aprender es capaz de crear es
capaz de dudar de sus resultados
eso nos dicen
pero
son realmente inteligentes las máquinas
que decís sí
no no lo son aprender dudar crear todos
estos son conceptos tremendamente
amplios son procesos de pensamiento muy
amplios son palabras como las definió
marvin minsky padre de la inteligencia
artificial son palabras
cofré palabras muy genéricas que
engloban otros procesos otros términos
mucho más concretos como son predecir
verificar identificar entonces si las
máquinas predicen verifican identifican
se podría decir que piensan aunque la
palabra correcta es procesa
identifican nuestros gustos
por eso facebook es tan bueno
personalizando sus anuncios a mí
últimamente no para de enseñarme pañales
y cunas a dónde clavo
'twitter cambia nuestro timeline para
enseñarlos las cosas de aquellos que más
nos interesan aunque nosotros no lo
hayamos manifestado así google cuando
estoy buscando ese término teclea unas
pocas letras y ya me aparecen o amazon
siempre está atentando te con esa última
compra que has hecho
pero que esta inteligencia parezca que
estas máquinas que estos algoritmos
parezcan inteligentes realmente lo hacen
hace que lo sean son más inteligentes
que digamos un niño de 2 años
ni por asomo entonces dónde está la
novedad porque el marketing no nos deja
de bombardear incluso mucha gente le
entra un poco de miedo
en qué punto está qué puede hacer aquí
quiero recuperar una reflexión que hizo
un investigador con el que trabajó mucho
hace unas pocas semanas comentaba que
cuando se estrenó la película 2001
odisea en el espacio' se les preguntó
tras ver la película a los que la habían
visto al salir que es lo que más les
había sorprendido de hal 9000 la máquina
la conocéis la habéis visto
muchos de ellos comentaron que les había
sorprendido enormemente que la máquina
fuera capaz de jugar al ajedrez
otros muchos comentaron que les había
sorprendido que fuera capaz de entender
de forma tan elocuente las órdenes de su
capitán
pero nadie absolutamente nadie reparó en
lo más característico de jal su ojo ese
ojo rojo ese ojo que luego inspirado
miles de series y películas que han
venido después de hecho aquí en españa
tenemos una serie de ciencia ficción que
indaga en la ética y moral del ser
humano buenísima vamos a por la
decimoctava temporada
inspirada en esto es ella gran hermano
el ojo nadie pensó en su momento y nadie
puede pensar ahora que el hecho de que
una máquina vea se es difícil pues lo es
de gran paraguas que es la inteligencia
artificial esta disciplina que lo
estudia se llama visión por computador
es una de las más complejas y aquí en
cataluña somos una potencia
entonces el desconocimiento es general
en qué punto está esta inteligencia que
puede que no puede hacer
la inteligencia artificial se divide en
dos tipos la inteligencia artificial
general y la inteligencia artificial
débil
la inteligencia artificial general de
esa estamos muy lejos sería la que
tenemos los humanos que podemos hacer
muchas cosas bien muchas cosas bien a la
vez y muchas cosas bien de formas
totalmente novedosas
en cambio la inteligencia artificial
débil que tiene estos carritos que
pueden hacer ahí
esta inteligencia artificial débil es
capaz de hacer una cosa muy muy bien muy
rápido incluso mejor que nosotros pero
solo esa cosa esa cosa a la vez y esa
cosa de la forma en que le hemos
enseñado a hacerlo y de hecho si le
enseñamos algo nuevo se le olvida lo que
sabía
en 2016
al fago un programa de ordenador ganó al
campeón del mundo y se done el juego con
el juego go es un juego muy popular
asiático en el que no sólo hay unas
reglas bien definidas sino que hace
falta un grado de intuición y
anticipación a los movimientos de tu
oponente pues bien este programa fue
capaz de batir al listado del campeón
por goleada
[Música]
pero si una vez acabado el torneo y en
esa misma tarima tras los aplausos de la
máquina hubiésemos preguntado les hemos
pedido a esa máquina que encontrara la
salida
o que se batiera unos huevos para
hacerse una tortilla por mucho que
hubiera tenido ruedecita si una manita
para batir hubiese sido totalmente
incapaz en cambio nuestro amigo se dore
un tanto batido seguro que pudo salir
dignamente de la sala y luego irse a su
hotel y batirse un par de huevos o
pedirlo en el restaurante abajo si el
hotel no tiene cocina
aunque hay aquí caricaturizado un poco
de inteligencia artificial débil es muy
buena haciendo una sola cosa para la
green y un ser entrenada durante miles
de horas y necesita miles de datos para
hacerlo pero nosotros todos se los hemos
regalado a través de millones de
búsquedas recopiladas en google a través
de nuestros estados en facebook
instagram en twitter a través de
nuestros pagos online nuestras
transacciones bancarias
y realmente es una herramienta de un
gran potencial
y como toda herramienta desde que el ser
humano creó el primer cuchillo de sílex
puede servir para mejorar nuestra
condición como humanos
o para empeorarla
para muestra un botón que enbridge a
analítica
esta consultora londinense salto o salto
en los medios esta noticia esta
consultora londinense
entro en los perfiles de miles de
usuarios de facebook influenciando así
su decisión de voto y favoreciendo
electoralmente favoreciendo
electoralmente a donald trump
pero por otro lado sabéis lo que es el
reconocimiento facial esto que hacen
estos cacharritos ahora de última
generación los sacamos y hacen
detecta nuestros patrones biométricos
verifican que soy yo y me dejan acceder
pues con esta tecnología la comisión
nacional de derechos infantiles de la
india ha escaneado miles de rostros de
niños desaparecidos
[Música]
y en tan solo cuatro días
ha identificado a más de 3000 niños
en una ciudad como es nueva delhi de 21
ó 75 millones de habitantes
sin esta tecnología hubiese sido
directamente imposible pero hay más con
esta misma tecnología podemos enseñarles
a los ordenadores a identificar el dolor
y en la uci la gente que no puede hablar
que no puede expresarse podemos detectar
si estás sintiendo dolor que el nivel de
dolor está sintiendo y dar aviso
enfermería para que sepa le podemos
enseñar a los ordenadores a leer texto
manuscrito a extraer la información que
hay contenida en miles de millones de
documentos alrededor del mundo que no
sabemos que pone y recuperar nuestro
legado histórico podemos enseñar a los
coches autónomos a conducir a reducir
drásticamente los accidentes en
carretera ya tener ciudades
descongestionadas y seguras
todo depende de qué queremos nosotros
como usuarios este debate de empezar
conmigo con el hampa con la asociación
de vecinos con los colegios
profesionales lo que los usuarios de
esta tecnología queramos que se haga con
esta con estos métodos con estas
herramientas
ahora bien
como vamos a saber si los resultados de
un algoritmo son éticos inclusivos
justos
si somos literalmente analfabetos
tecnológicos
y no ya nosotros me preocupa este
pequeñín aquí las siguientes
generaciones los que vendrán ha cambiado
algo en la forma de enseñar el lenguaje
primario de esta tecnología que son las
matemáticas
tal como va nuestro sistema público
educativo van a poder competir en un
mundo digital un mundo que cada vez está
más presente
la revolución que supone la inteligencia
artificial es equiparable a la
revolución que supuso la
industrialización del siglo 18 marcará
un cambio profundo en estas vidas y
tenemos que ponernos las pilas
pero con esto no estoy diciendo que
todos nuestros hijos y nietos el día de
mañana tengan que ser
programadores profesionales en absoluto
esto es como la alfabetización hace 200
años la mayoría la gente no sabía leer
ni escribir hoy en día todos podemos
pero esto no nos hace inmediatamente
escritores de best sellers con esta
tecnología debe ocurrir lo mismo debemos
poder comprender su esencia básica
y el cambio del modelo educativo no
viene por introducir más tecnología en
las aulas
que el niño esté todo el día enganchado
al ordenador ipad no implica que vaya a
entender mejor cómo funciona el cambio
del modelo educativo debe venir por cómo
tenemos esas habilidades matemáticas por
cómo podemos llegar a entender la lógica
de esta tecnología
[Música]
pero si para mí sí para nosotros y para
mí como madre hoy no es una prioridad
para nuestros legisladores tampoco lo va
a ser
y tampoco lo será mi hijo el día que vea
que no entiende la sociedad digital en
la que vive
por su futuro por nuestro futuro por el
de todos cambiemos lo
[Aplausos]
sí